hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hooniepop2
i'm sorry for the delay between my
broken foot and everything that's been
going on that i needed to catch up on i
haven't had a chance to play this again
but i'm back
so don't worry ladies
don't worry i have no idea where i was
but i'm sure i'll pick it up
you'd be surprised how many porn
channels they have here
honestly it's mostly porn channels
i'm gonna guess on an island called
inadepuna it's gonna be a lot of porn
okay who do we have
oh
all right jesse and lola get out there
and don't come back until you've
contracted something horrible
what jesse there you are hey girl i was
starting to wonder if we'd ever find
each other
ah my sweet lola how you doing
girlfriend
i missed you um missed you too babe
i missed you sorry i've been so busy the
past few months things have just been
crazy lately what a coincidence but hey
i promised you that rain check and did
your girl deliver or what
i gotta admit this vacation was one of
your more brilliant ideas
i really needed it i deliver large
packages
are things between you and tiffany still
a little rocky
and on top of that now she has me
blocked on social media too
oh oh don't worry angel face she'll come
around
you'll see is it because we are now just
enjoy yourself
girl we're on vacation
love the way you guys just ignore me but
that's okay
hey i'm sensing something a long history
from before remember uh
like years ago when we anyway hey wow
you're actually looking at my face i was
not actually
you must have something important to say
i really wasn't to be perfectly honest
um school how was that
must have just been like a few years ago
right high school didn't last long for
me
but i liked history class because i had
a huge crush on my teacher
[Music]
that's right i forgot how much we
actually have in common
what we have in common who's the teacher
wait
you're not the same age you weren't in
school at the same time what is going on
here
whatever hi you know what i've always
wondered about you what
do you think there should be more women
in positions of power
yeah yeah absolutely both of these are
true
qualified exactly when i get to the top
i want to know i earned it with
sacrifice and hard work
that's fair everyone deserves a shot i
feel like i can trust you
to be honest with me no sometimes i
wonder
would i have been better off if i chose
not to have my daughter
oh my god
kids do put your dreams on hold and i'm
sure it wasn't easy raising her alone
well you know this is a lot
i'm just trying to get laid or i'm just
trying to do
puzzles what would i say in this to put
your dinner sure it wasn't easy raising
around there's no point thinking about
that me
i'm of the philosophy you can't go back
and change the past well
thanks but i'm not exactly sure how that
helps if it's not supposed to help what
are you supposed to do about it
you're in the now whatever oh i just
remembered something i was going to ask
you
what what advice would you give to a
person that just graduated high school
another user account it feels way less
good that's bad if i stick a year off to
travel the world
life isn't fair and complaining about it
doesn't help how about travel
you're a flight attendant you think so
hmm i don't know about that ah
i should have done with the whole with
her personality
because i always just cater my answers
to their personality
also apparently someone said that this
is a this other symbol is the one that
yeah it's the one they don't like
that's gonna help a lot the game you
told me that one okay cool well this is
fine hey
i have a lot of nachos it has been like
weeks
these nachos are gone what would you
like jesse you're a classy gal
you're a woman in charge you're a snow
bunny
okay you're a flip floppy
oh you don't have stamina you want candy
you want candy
you want you want candy you want can
candy
candy ah not fair you know all of my
weaknesses
i do like your pressure point that
causes your boobs to explode
uh snow bunny oh those are
cute okay you're a classy gal
you've known me for over two years and
you don't know what kind of shoes i like
oh my god uh a
woman in charge you don't never know
you want some chocolates cupcake cupcake
cupcake you want a cupcake but i'm such
a foodie
i know you are those are pretty cute
okay that's probably the other lady that
i don't really like
are you uh but i just
no okay never mind let's just forget i
said anything
what i don't think pumping their boobies
is gonna up their stamina
i don't think that's give you a slow i
have nothing to say about that
not really my style though well what is
your style then let's go on a date
to turn down a good time hey don't get
ahead of yourself
good time may not happen
this is the kind of date i always
imagined being taken on
yeah better late than never better life
than ever
okay i've actually i believe that i've
grown additional brain cells since the
last time that i did this so this should
be a lot easier
than before i definitely gave them gifts
gifts are definitely there
perfect i knew you would like that
because i know you so well
god this is romantic i am just swimming
in romance
haven't lost your size i have so much
touch that you don't even know about
i might be dumb i'm just taking my time
with it because i'm trying to actually
be strategic about this and if i
if i flub this then you know well no
one's going to be surprised but if i
flub it then i flub it
[Music]
man i'm not getting big numbers this is
going poorly
because i'm only seeing threes and i
know that there's gotta be worlds where
i don't just see threes but threes is
all i sees
so i'm kind of in trouble if this is the
case
there's sentiment here converts all
broken oh well first let me get this
sentiment
let me get this this girl don't need no
charity oh you can't be the
30 percent passion never mind okay 30
passion okay you got to have your
passion up
right well that's easy enough right here
got that okay convert okay
well okay uh okay
my genius brain is wrinkling into
another dimension of
intelligence as we speak
[Music]
that was a good combo for all my
stupidity i sure am smart
and now what's this
guy i am that guy what a guy what did
you say what kind of guy
sorry i got distracted by your sweater i
don't know how that stays up i don't
think gravity works that way are the
sleeves separate parts do they just is
it all one
tube and then two two uh whatever i'm
not
i'm not gonna worry about i'll analyze
it later
on okay i'm gonna get a little more
sentiment
[Music]
okay we're gonna get a lot more of those
and we're gonna get some of this
smart news that was a smart move thank
you and then your turn
you get this no yes no yes
no yes no yes no yes no yes
yes no you get this
okay you get that too you get
this pretty cool right now
it is hot hey what's up loli
what did you happen to what you okay oh
right
you just failed to recover stamina
you're fine actually well you're not
fine that's that's no good
i feel bad about that but you know
you'll you'll catch your breath
i hope hey what's up you want some
passion we don't really need passion but
passion might set up something else no
it did not uh okay
move this
uh you know it said though there was
going to be a lot more of the blue
tokens but there really aren't that many
blue tokens that i'm seeing so it's
actually kind of
[ __ ] uh you kind of lied to me game
[Music]
this looks lovely it seems like there's
a setup here but there really
isn't you know if you really think about
it there's actually not it's very
deceptive many reds
none that i could use unless no none
that i could use
it's really sad the way that is be it
but if i do this i think
it'll actually get closer what
yes
we're laughing uh we're almost through
this the nightmare is almost over
um will that cause a calamity i feel
like this might cause a calamity
it did not cause a calamity all right
ladies
it is about to be uh snooze time
getting late for me i got a busy day
ahead of me
you don't like that do you you like this
don't you
you like that pretty okay um i'm still a
little bit distant but i'm gonna give
you your favorite
smart view we're so close
and then we'll finish it off with that
and bada bing bada boom
i love that tube your dress is nice too
lola
you never cease to amaze me well not so
far
anyway but trust me oh my god lola
you know what this reminds me of do you
remember that one time we got drunk and
made out with each other for like 30
minutes
wow one time jesse we've made out at
least half a dozen times
why really how come i don't remember
that
you are usually wasted you start getting
pretty handsy once you're drunk
i can't help it you know alcohol makes
me horny
how come you didn't stop me i don't
drink
well i don't know maybe
maybe i didn't mind it so much
i don't mind it either i could go an
hour maybe an hour and a half
you know anyway all right i'll clean off
the table you guys
you get out of here you too let me know
if you do that makeup thing
all right who is this new character at
the marina
i will see to you and then you will see
to me
lovely night for it this is my yacht
hello where is this chick
it's late again as usual
my eyes are up at your eyes shh
keep it down will ya i ain't trying to
get caught alright
oh run sorry
it's fine it's fine anyway i got your
stuff you got the money
the cocaine jesus are you stupid
how many times i got to tell you to be
quiet
shoot sorry yeah
i'm also here whatever here's your [ __ ]
did you say cocaine
wow i give up that's some good
stuff who's that guy over there watching
us
i'm here what's up guys hi it's me
don't run it okay bye
whoa yeah whoa who is this angel
i don't know she's like an 11. no
a 12 [ __ ] this is the kind of chick
that's so hot you almost wouldn't mind
getting the hurt from her
you know you told me to this [ __ ] is so
hot i would pay her just to spit in my
face
i would suck her knees
i would chug a two liter of her genital
juice like i was a competitive [ __ ]
eater
hot there handsome you're just gonna
stand there
yeah you're gonna come talk to me i know
this is weird me making expressions like
this while i'm just standing there and
no one else is here talking to a fairy
that's flying right here
she says you're 12. i mean you're very
pretty but
12 is pretty anyway how are you what's
your name
i'd introduce myself but i forgot my
name as soon as i i didn't my name is
markiplier can i just start out by
saying that you look absolutely
ravishing that's terrible sorry i was
talking about
that's what i was saying
[Music]
yeah i don't remember this one's names
yeah she's dumb
i can't i think i'm in love uh-huh
my name's candace oh i'm a dancer
at the strip club okay you should come
and visit me
all right uh how much do you charge for
yeah i
listen i don't exactly have money i have
a lot of fruit
like a lot of fruit that is exploded out
of the chests of random women
that i have been taking out on dates and
as soon as i
solve my sudoku that i'm working at the
table and not talking to them
fruit just happens to explode i have
that how much do you charge
depends on the night i think tomorrow
it's two for one songs if you want
i'll blow you behind that building for
20 bucks
oh so much for these panties
i'm gonna go change nobody have sex
while i'm gone
uh no thank you i'm okay um
i don't have cash listen um
i have fruit how much fruit would you
like it's got to have a monetary value
over 20 bucks
oh well maybe some other time then
yeah yeah i guess okay it's just you
sorry to run off like that but yo you
scared the [ __ ] out of me
i do that hi again nora yeah
hi candice same time next week
any cocaine for me ladies cocaine
the cocaine the cocaine that you were
just training
for money anyway all right i have shoes
for you
i have the shoes for you here you go you
got these for little old man
[Music]
yeah they are okay good i'm glad you
like them because i like them
for you i'm listening i'm what oh
i'm asking apparently uh online
i don't get to see my cousin that much
so i like doing those online video chats
oh it ain't that's exactly what i love
my goodness you are very
i'm not gonna say you're dumb but you're
not smart are you
what are you gonna ask me i'm thinking
about it oh
it's my turn oh can you guess what i'm
thinking about right now
uh a small furry animal
hey yeah how do you know
i was thinking about a little baby chick
quack quack
okay all right you know this is okay
that's okay
what is your favorite thing star and you
moon star
your exact opposites this is perfect
okay
star star okay that's good
oh that's good that's good okay this
will balance out the um
passion so if i load candace up with
passion
candace could give nora some passion in
equivalent return okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay oh this
like having the broken hearts gone is is
essential
i think okay so this is good hey ladies
you guys want to go on a date
you two are gonna go play together i
wanna play too
yeah you can play we'll play like
scrabble or something
is there a strip scrabble oh what am i
about to
endure wow now this
here's a lot fancier than the back
alleyway
yeah you're right yeah wow good
observation
um god damn this music is sexy hold on
for a minute i don't think we're getting
that far just yet we just met
and i'm slipping into the accent and i
don't think i'm gonna escape it at this
juncture
so uh everyone just be calm and we will
get along
just fine but you you will enjoy
some of this all right all right all
right all right
yeah you wouldn't mind something a
little
similar to this because it's gonna set
me up for the most incredible stamina
play of your existence oh
i feel you you feel me feel this
yay indeed the passion has only just
begun
god damn that's hot the music is so sexy
so sensual
i feel it in my soul you yes
okay still not getting what i need there
and i wanted to bring a heart down but i
cannot
oh i can bring a heart over though okay
so you already have passion so i'm gonna
give you more
passion so that you can eventually
transfer your passion over to
nora i'll give you some stamina so that
i can
set up this play
and then hopefully get an orton now i
didn't get an orange but
more passion and potentially another
orange nope we're getting somewhere
though
lots of blues stacking up i'm gonna get
this orange
i'll start out with this first
damn it i shouldn't why did i start out
with that first oh
well i'm an idiot is that going to be
okay cool cool cool yes take this
passion i expected a bit more than a
giggle but that's okay
we need some sentiment some
sentimentality
okay so if this consumes all of those
that'll be very helpful
oh well i didn't know that it was going
to oh my god i didn't know that that was
the
i didn't know when you said consume i
thought it meant something other than
you just
eat it all up at once ah shoot
okay it's fine because i'm gonna set
this up so that i definitely have some
stamina here because nora is upset
what i'm gonna do is i'm going to ensure
this is like an insurance policy i'm
going to put this here so that drops the
grade down one level so it's on the same
level as those and that way i won't get
in trouble
if i don't have the right thing where it
needs to be
then i could immediately give stamina so
that i never run out
and there's the what i was looking for
yay hooray that's what you said and for
some reason you still
don't have an orange in this slot here
it's fine
it's whatever it's okay i guess let's
just
let's give it two for one you gonna stop
being a [ __ ] now
well you're one to talk okay you
this is fine i'm gonna get an orange in
this column eventually
someday i will get a goddamn orange in
that column
there we go finally god
now we blast nora
in the face with moons
[Applause]
i know here we go
i am good i am good
i'm very good the best
some say many say actually most
actually would say that i am the best
this here bam get another move don't
piss anyone off
uh let's just do small moves that's
going to make it anyway
done deal baby done deal that took a
long time
but hey i take my tire
i take my time with my dates i've
learned it's better gold star
and a smiley face ticket where are you
gonna put it
nora you think maybe i could get a
little hit for free
pretty please candace you ever think
about maybe cutting back a little
you go pretty hard but it makes me feel
all
good and sad yeah but
there's like other ways to feel good you
know
there is what's that
i don't know maybe we could like figure
something out
like an exploratory mission like
some spelunking that needs to occur is
that what you're saying here
is that what you mean is that what
you're talking about hey
attracted and horny or i could get
terrible and stupid i'm gonna unlock the
other character first this might be the
last character that needs to be unlocked
hey i'll see you later you enjoy the
room
i paid for it but i paid for it in fruit
so honestly they're gonna come after me
soon so i gotta run
nice crab they don't even have a star
brand here
oh my god
know how would you know place a few
stores back
that way they sell most of the same
drinks as star brand
what the hell is wrong with you thanks
again
i'll go check it out uh
whoa whoa load of this chick
yeah i thought you banged the alien girl
last time
i know why you're here uh huh
did she just say what i think she said
you're here to awaken them
right the cosmic ones
you're not from the ca or something area
no i believe
my information comes from a much higher
place higher you see i've had dreams
i've seen things things i can't
explain no i believe
that i may have some kind of connection
with the spirit world
yeah oh i get it she's a crazy person
hmm i don't know why but i knew i had to
come here to ina de puna and seek you
out
i don't like this this is all sounding
crazy
but i like crazy crazy is it any crazier
than
an invisible being you're talking to one
of them now
aren't you how can you tell butterfly
people
okay now i'm officially creeped out
well someone has seen what happens if
you should fail your task
and so i wish to help in any way i can
thank you you heard about the horrible
ball explosion
punishment that is impending within days
or moments i actually don't know when
how do you feel about three things if
that is what's required yes
and that is what i'll do yes absolutely
if i sense compatibility between myself
and another
i will do my best to attract her
know who this [ __ ] is or how she knows
any of this [ __ ]
but i ain't asking questions yeah no
all the help we can get besides she's
pretty cute once you get past the crazy
thing
well i mean it's not crazy as we
determined i am talking to a butterfly
person
forever of course they had to get my
order wrong the first time
oh yes i feel a strong connection with
this one
may i ask your name who me
um lillian
it's a beautiful name for a beautiful
soul
i was born denise but i go by zoe now
okay
i sense something here and the
uncertainty
lillian you're usually insulting someone
by now hey how you doing
why do i even bother getting out of bed
in the morning
i don't know why do you even
bother coming to enudapuna if they don't
have a star browns
so you can get laid that's what i did
yeah that's like basically the only good
thing about life
i'm stuck on this stupid island without
my tablet
my parents hate me my life is worthless
and
everything sucks i mean what the [ __ ]
is even the point of life anyway we're
all just gonna die in the end
fair enough you know you got a real good
point there lillian
oh my god okay hey what's up how you
doing it's faint
but i'm picking up a signal from someone
on this island
it's a past filled with hardship and
betrayal
this one's walled herself off to avoid
being hurt again
oh uh oh this sounds like
jesse nora well yeah i guess it could be
but also could be jessie but also could
be nora
sounds like might be nora moore i had a
strong feeling you were going to know
this name
ah are you psychic are you connected to
like the
the internet all right i'm gonna give
you guys gifts okay cyber boots
you're welcome it's not often i'm able
to find a pair of boots that conforms to
my aesthetic
okay you're you're welcome
you take this ring good this would look
good on you
no that is a good one i'm gonna buy it
anyway but for later
not for now
[Music]
that's not pretty good anything to get
rid of the broken hearts that doesn't
involve consuming them let's date
now i mean if you guys are going i'm not
going to stay here by myself
yeah life is worthless there's no point
but i might as well come along
to this massage what a beautiful spa
a peaceful place to restore and reunify
the body
mind and spirit
you have those right you're not some
robo are you
[Music]
wait you didn't like that one did you
damn it god damn it i did
fine it's fine
nice nice nice nice don't worry you
don't need to say anything about it i
know how incredible that was that's two
stamina
um just put me in the morgue
already joy matches directed lillian
it's fine it's okay
i see yes i see two also
okay we can still win this even though i
just lost
a lot of moves because that was a four
move combo
but whatever it's fine
okay you are almost out of stamina that
is a problem
so let's fix that
we're gonna lose this we're gonna lose
it somehow somehow we're gonna lose this
all right let's just do this
you have my toy so do what you need to
do with it
oh i know i can get a combo about this i
have to get as
like every single other move from now on
has to be a combo or
i am kind of boned oh here we go
okay you yes uh not that yes
okay perfect this you now
this caboose there we go
okay that was a good move ah i see
second
move here kaboom i
feel i don't feel that you're also gonna
get this
this move token maybe i could get more
let's
hold out for a little more 12 seconds
later you know what i'm not
i'm not gonna ruin it i'm just gonna go
for the move i don't think i'm gonna get
better
i don't think it's gonna get better okay
so this
i need sentiment from you now oh
i see a good move okay let's get the
sentiment first
let's blast out some passion juice
kaboom
yeah okay so your passion is now tip top
so what we need to do now is we need to
set up so that we can take advantage of
that
and just oh i've got so far and so
little left let's try
to get that blue we could oh my god
oh thank you thank you love god
so if i move this here to get more
sentiment that brings those
reds closer if i make that heart go down
afterwards
that's also good
you see what i'm going for everybody
everybody at home you see what i'm
getting at
i make this heart go down here that
brings this to this level
sets this up here this will exhaust lily
and let's not do that
just yet so let's do the other one first
it's not ideal we need to get
this over there for those bells but for
now this is okay
fascinating it is fascinating i know
okay so this red is ready
maybe ooh maybe i should do this first
yeah i like it i love that okay good
okay good okay good everything's working
out everything's good
everything's great actually everything's
fantastic
blast this out that's a big boost
not bad we got seven moves seven
beautiful delicious moves delightful
perfect moves coming up okay if i do
this
it drops that down the bells at least
would be lined up
might set up some star potential yeah
let's do it so there's star potential
here for a
fiver and that would be pretty good if i
make those bells connect it ruins the
fiber potential
but you know there's still a four
potential there i think it's okay
well no there won't be a four potential
there
i'm gonna have to use that eventually
i'm gonna have to this is some strategy
this is more strategy than i've ever
employed in any
any game i've ever played okay weirdly
enough this works
okay this is weird but it works so what
i need to do i know this isn't
her thing but if i do this here she has
enough stamina for this
here i see
we're still far okay we have four moves
but there's plenty of bells on the board
if i bring this down here get stamina
up that drops the bell down to that same
level the
other bell is on
okay is there any way that i could make
these a four
e this might work or it might just ruin
everything
with that oh no it wouldn't i'd be
one too far ah [ __ ] god
frick oh frick i think i just screwed
myself
no did i just screw myself
i'm going for broke it's
too far god damn it oh no
oh make zoe ups oh
god damn it oh screw me
i mean i could do a red there but then
that moves that blue way but the
red might work better here oh but i
can't because
oh [ __ ] let's just see what this does
it's gonna put the bell too low but it's
whatever at this point
i don't think i'm gonna make it bam
it's close one move left
i probably should have just done this
from the get-go but uh this will put me
at
two moves is there any okay let's
analyze this
i've only got 60 i need to come up with
is there anything that would cause
any kind of a cascade that might help me
put that there if i put this all the way
there
i feel your energy oh no it's not enough
probably if i didn't do that other
stupid move trying to get that i might
have had enough
god damn it
frick there might have been a way but
whatever god if i hadn't
god i read her a bill i literally was
like i wonder what her ability is
right after i do the goddamn thing
okay all right whatever all right let's
let's make it up quick with exploring
some
uh some uh compatibility let's let's
just go on with it you know what
i don't even want to talk i don't even
want to talk i wasted so much time for
your first dance me too
i'm here i hope so
we'll start with my favorite twerking
it's fun you just arch your back and
jiggle your buns my buns
um i was hoping we could start with
something
a little less suggestive
uh-huh oh sorry you mean like
a chair dancing i was thinking
maybe something like hula
oh okay sure
who is easy it's all in the hips
uh-huh great i can tell there is a spark
of something special here
uh and speaking of spark of something
special i have a gift
for you that i bought here you go how do
you know
i just noticed the strap was coming
loose on my other bear
i noticed that too don't ask me how i
noticed it
but i noticed it okay
let's do earrings i had earrings
well i'm not gonna give you two that's
for sure but i'll give you this whatever
i don't know what's good let's just go
let's just go
let's just go i have to make up for what
it i did before
yeah yeah it's awful nice of me it's
just you wait until the date
i suppose it's never too late to learn
how to play new
yeah new game like this one which i
haven't learned yet uh
let's go for the obvious move first
actually you know what i'm gonna save
those because eventually those might
come into play
if i'm able to actually make some kind
of a match there
well this no that'd be a waste here we
go
[Music]
great start i feel like i've never
concentrated this much in a game ever
i'm as focused as i could possibly be
because i do
not want to mess up i don't have
anything that could that's going to get
rid of the flowers
but i've got this thing which is going
to give me way more moves
because there's a lot of bells on the
field so that's a good move
and then i can't give you the passion
but i can give you the passion
definitely
or the passion fashion no
sucker the the vivacity whatever that is
i don't
i i for some reason i'm blanking on the
name but you guys know what i'm talking
about
right like saying you know what i'm
talking about right good great thank you
[Music]
why will that make oh
okay well if i'm gonna if i'm gonna do
this anyway it'll make her upset but
also she was gonna be low salmon anyway
this is a tactical move
bam tactics
tactics but she's upset but she'll be
fine she'll get over it okay then this
also tactics
boom excellent okay so i just need to no
no no can't exhaust her cause that would
ruin everything
not gonna do that you get the bell
and you get the stamina
wow why was that mad again i don't
remember
you know it's so funny you'll exhaust oh
don't exhaust
don't exhaust at all um let's just do
this
what blam okay now you're not gonna
exhaust
boom big moves i thought that was gonna
be more but i forgot you kind of lower
stamina but that's
or a passion but that's okay uh
this is getting close to us something
this is getting close to us something
there's a something that's what we oh
you don't like that something
god why don't you like that something
why isn't that something that you like
nah that looks like something but it
ain't something why does no one like my
somethings
you already have max passion you don't
need more passion but you do need moons
but you're not gonna
that's gonna exhaust you so we need a a
one-off
for you this
is okay because this is the one no i
need stamina now
[Music]
oh thank you
now you've got sentiment back up on that
your stamina is now safe because we're
going to have
more so
this is the way this is the way
this is the way what am i doing
oh my god i'm actually far away this is
tough
i keep accidentally making candace upset
i don't mean to
it just happens don't
worry i still like you do
you do you for realsies
is it for truesies what if i bring this
down
[Music]
oh no that was a waste of move
okay i cannot waste moves i cannot
we are the bestest didn't do anything
it is what we're gonna do i'm gonna do
this
i'm gonna do this
getting really close now it's gonna be
down to the wire a bit but that's okay
double move here this is good you love
to see it you
love to see that and i think we're in
the clear i think we're good how much do
we need 15. this is gonna do it
four oh frick um boom
we're there that would have been fine i
should have done that long time ago i
didn't know that did the
hey there we go i'm not gonna worry
about it hey how you doing hey what's
going on here sucks
yes and speaking of suck
thank you so much for inviting me says i
had a wonderful time
i'm glad you did gosh
i wish i had your confidence candace the
way you carry yourself is so
natural i'm confident you get it you
just gotta learn to be comfortable in
your own skin
i don't know i'm so awkward
maybe i'm just not cut out for dancing
don't say
that i just gotta get you in tune with
your body's natural
truth i have no rhythm
well sure you do don't worry
i'll show you i got just the train i
got tricks too i have many tricks
halloween is my favorite time of year
[Music]
hello okay anyway i guess we're done
here so thank you everybody
welcome back to hoonie pop we're gonna
finish this up in no time flat
we're gonna plow through this game and
plow through these girls so thank you
everybody so much for watching
you are all depraved ingrates for
watching this and how dare you but thank
you so much for sticking it out
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
oh